[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KYLE KEANE: All right.
So this movement happening
above the screen.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT: So the original
inspiration was from Minecraft.
And we were kind of
constructing this cubes freely
with different textures.
And we made this with Kinect.
So basically with
one hand you can
control the position of your
character, which is a ball.
And with the other
hand, you can decide
whether to create,
which is going up,
and eat, which is going down.
So because now we are
deleting this cubes.
STUDENT: Also you can
assign the [INAUDIBLE]
to the existing cube.
Will you please?
But when you use--
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: Always gauge.
But when you use the
hand out, it will delete.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: So it's a little
bit hard to select.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: Sometimes you
[INAUDIBLE] confuse--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT: And
actually we also plan
to create some examples
so that the user can
plan what they want to construct
and follow the instruction.
Maybe some can.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT: It looks like you've
made it so the cubes are
on a grid, right?
Is that correct?
They're not just
randomly located--
STUDENT: Oh yes.
At first we had the problem
that, when the cube is created,
it overlapped each other.
So then we do make
it at the position
that is in tangent because the
cube has side, a unique cube.
So it will not overlap anymore.
And in the future, we may
consider group the object.
So we either go to move the
whole one object together.
For example, if you have
a house or anything,
then you can move
it at one time.
KYLE KEANE: Anybody
have any questions?
STUDENT: And there's
a palette that you
use to recolor the objects?
STUDENT: Oh yes.
There's on the other
side if you can.
STUDENT: Only five colors
but we can add more?
STUDENT: If you just
demo, you could actually
pick different colors--
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: It's literally
hard to think.
MARC VRABLIC: [INAUDIBLE].
Because it's kind of
awkward to draw with.
That's one of the best
things about Pictionary,
when people can't draw.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT: Also we
think that it may
be intuitive to use two
hands to create and object
instead of one hand and
use the other [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]